I'm Aubrey Plaza and I'm currently under
a blanket with Craig Robinson for this
wired is looking back to under a blanket
with Craig and offering or and Holly way
they call is robbery is Aubrey Plaza
single done I just answered it that's
none of your business as my grandmother
would say never tell them anything
his Audrey Plaza Spanish yes I am
actually
I just recently did my 23andme and I'm
30 or 31 percent Irish I'm like 34
percent Iberian which is Spanish I'm ten
percent West African that's nine point
nine in your face I'm seven percent
Native American I'm like oh and I'm
point six percent Ashkenazi Jewish I
like to round up to one on that one I
have the exact same numbers and exact
same categories is Aubrey Plaza in
Legend of Korra okay I'm the one that
wrote that one you need the internet to
test if you were in tiny children once
followed me home and said we love you on
the last airbender you're the ice
princess and I had no zero recollection
of doing that voiceover but apparently I
did it for years is Aubrey Plaza in Game
of Thrones
no I'm not in Game of Thrones but I feel
like Peter Dinklage and I have our own
Game of Thrones if you know what I mean
thousands game of Oh was Fred Robinson
on friends were you yes I had a scene
with Phoebe where I changed her name I
was a government worker
she went our name-change to banana
hammock that's not our Craig Robinson
and Andy Samberg friends absolutely what
about that fight that you got in that
was you know a fight between friends
then things happen I got pushed in the
swimming pool it was Craig Robinson
stomp for me and anybody who's ever seen
my comedy routine Craig Robinson the
office I'm gonna go with this was an
image search I think that she died as
soon as a question mark Craig Robinson
the office I think this person wanted to
see those pics Craig Robinson Cleveland
Browns were you either they saying I'm
tough like Jim Brown who was on the
Cleveland Browns
or they say I look like Cleveland Brown
the cartoon that's real
I'm just gonna go with Jim Brown Act was
crazy because my character on Cleveland
Show is like he looks like Jim Brown
what are you talking about next car over
I'll be present ain't
Chris Pratt friends Andy he did get a
restraining order against me a couple
months ago but I think he was just
kidding our Amy Poehler and Aubrey Plaza
still friends we are all on a part Parks
and Rec mass text chain which somebody
updates at least every other day and
[Music]
straight answer does Aubree Plaza have a
sister I have two sisters
oh that's none of your business that's
my family you know the Hobby Plaza have
an instagram my instagram is plus a day
I'll bring but I'm getting off that
does Aubree Pleasant play World of
Warcraft
okay I'm sorry that I was on a world of
warcraft commercial one time that
doesn't mean that I play it every night
next card
lightning round
where does Craig Robinson live
California Los Angeles where is Craig
Robinson what does this mean
they probably talk about me coaching
acting or singing and that's just on
site you know just about $45 and where
did Craig Robinson go to college
Illinois State University to Nome and my
my master's in a st. Xavier University
where is Craig Robinson now I'm under a
blanket with Aubrey Plaza please don't
what is Aubrey Plaza doing now what
personality type is Aubrey Plaza thank
you okay so I recently did the I believe
it's the Jungian personality test I'm an
ENFJ infj yeah something like that
what does Aubrey Plaza eat what does you
know you can sit there read this card
you can see the level on the barrel they
say like okay they heard about you and
they won't know who's the zombie Plaza
I've been hearing about I'm taking it
all very personally is Craig Robinson
Mormon but but I do like Mitt Romney Oh
God is Craig Robinson a version we had
to die
evolve it's Craig Robinson define
married is it possible to be in a
relationship and feel like you're
married but you haven't actually got
married yeah if you have a ball and
chain wrapped around your ankle Craig
Robinson related to Michelle Obama in a
way because I went to the same high
school Michelle Obama
that's not then I'm related to but no I
said his career I didn't say this Craig
Robinson but there she does have a
brother and his name is Craig Robinson
it's Craig Robinson in Ocean's eleven
don't be burning Mac you're thinking of
thank you for all the awesome questions
you gave to Aubrey and then just kind of
figured out who I am through this whole
it means they assumed you're in a hit
movie yeah you got hobbies personality
this Greg Robinson Bernie Mac all the
people that google me you want to drop
me up into a million pieces you kill me
it's great Robinson dead can we go go
out what comes up happens thanks for
watching this hope you learned something
goodnight probably out